bienvenue bienvenue à tous ravis de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
paris saclay tv c'est la rentrée pour
nous pour vous et pour tous les
étudiants de paris saclay nous sommes à
l'estac à cette grande école
d'ingénieurs s'est installé à montigny
le bretonneux
elle se mobilise pour que les jeunes
filles soient de plus en plus nombreuses
à se lancer dans des carrières
scientifiques nous verrons comment
à suivre aussi ce coup de projecteur sur
le chantier de l'aisne 6e paris tech
l'école nationale de la statistique et
de l'administration économique de
déménager à palaiseau dans le quartier
de l'école polytechnique
nous allons découvrir ensemble ce
bâtiment plutôt ce projet architectural
ces chercheurs ces chercheuses pourront
prétendre à une bourse du conseil
européen de la recherche
cette institution soutient les meilleurs
scientifiques indépendants mais comment
décrocher ce graal
nous avons rencontré le président de lé
rc
il s'agit de jean pierre bourguignon et
enfin une exposition étonnante quand
l'art de la rue s'invite au cea
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives
cela donne peu égal nc215s découvrez les
portraits d'einstein de marie curie ou
même de david bowie et portraits si ces
215 et enfin n'oublions pas notre agenda
tous les évènements à ne surtout pas
rater ce sera à la fin de cette émission
mais d'abord paris saclay et tv vous
emmène sur le chantier de lenz a eu
paris tech à palaiseau dans le quartier
de l'école polytechnique l'école
nationale de la statistique et de
l'administration économique va
s'installer dans un bâtiment conçu
imaginé par l' agence cab un projet
architectural que nous découvrons dans
sanglots
on se trouve ici devant le chantier de
l'ancv paristech nos locaux actuels sont
situés à malakoff et donc nous allons
déménager dans un an sur le plateau de
saclay ce bâtiment il nous permettra
d'accueillir davantage d'étudiants
environ 700 800 étudiants contre 500
actuellement des enseignants-chercheurs
et donc d'être au sein du plateau de
saclay un pôle pour l'économie la
sociologie les sciences sociales et les
sciences des données l'origine du projet
c'est un c'est un concours
d'architecturé qui a eu lieu en 2011
donc avec mes associés beat azimi et
marc godinot nous avons gagné ce
concours c'est un bâtiment qui fait
seize mille 5000 mètres carrés donc sur
sur un rez-de-chaussée 4 4 niveaux donc
c'était à la fois de créer un petit vide
clos d'un d'un cloître
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui plaît beaucoup
aux chercheurs et puis d'abord un
bâtiment aussi qui s'ouvre totalement
sur le paysage sercan fait en gros
toutes les façades sont vitrées à 100%
nous ce qui nous intéressait donc
c'était à la fois de mettre en dialogue
le bâtiment par sa structure qui est une
exhaust rupture métallique en résonance
avec avec les arbres avec le bois avec
les troncs avec la nature et puis aussi
donc de rendre ce bâtiment extrêmement
flexible c'est à dire aussi de penser à
peut-être dans une vingtaine d'années où
avant ou plus tard que ce bâtiment
pourrait se transformer paris saclay
c'est pour nous un espace de partenariat
quasiment sans équivalent en france le
déménagement va clairement nous
permettre de nous rapprocher de nos
partenaires que sont l'école
polytechnique hec l'école normale
supérieure de cachan et l'université
paris sud et les organismes de recherche
les autres établissements qui qui sont
sur le plateau déjà au qui ont vocation
il déménager dans les prochaines années
ce nouveau bâtiment accueillera 875
étudiants d'autres grandes écoles se
sont déjà installés c'est le cas de
l'estaca qui vient tout juste
d'emménager à montigny le bretonneux
une école qui se mobilisent pour que les
jeunes filles soient de plus en plus
nombreuses à se lancer dans des
carrières scientifiques
elles sont encore un peu trop timide il
faut donc les sensibiliser
à l'estaca donc école d'ingénieurs
spécialisée sur les transports et la
mobilité
nous avons entre 10 et 15 % de filles
dans vos promotions ce qui est trop peu
à notre goût quel instinct paristech la
proportion de filles et de 30 % 70 % de
nos diplômés on des postes en recherche
et développement et plus de 20% pour
suivante est ce cette proportion
satisfaisant évidemment j'aimerais bien
la parité mais déjà 30% pour une école
d'ingénieurs scientifique c'est déjà un
taux élevé donc il ya dix ans on a créé
une association qui s'appelle elle bouge
qui aujourd'hui devenue une grande
association avec de multiples écoles et
de multiples partenaires industriels en
son sein dont l'objectif est justement à
travers un système de marrainage de
susciter des carrières l'envi de devenir
ingénieur
nous intervenons avec l'association
elles bougent dans les lycées pour
montrer aux jeunes filles bien que c'est
possible qu'il n'y a pas de frein à
avoir et qu'on a quand on a une
motivation et une envie de faire des
sciences
et bien c'est aussi possible que quinze
garçons et on est très fiers cette année
sur la promotion qui est sorti on
constate une parité de salaire sur nos
diplômés filles et garçons mais ce n'est
pas le cas dans tous dans tous les
secteurs donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose qui montre aussi qu'il ya
un progrès
sur le côté technique elles vont
résoudre le problème de la même manière
parce qu'elles ont reçu la même
formation
par contre elles vont intégrer des
facteurs environnementaux des facteurs
sociétaux des facteurs humains que
n'atteindre bron pas ou moins facilement
les garçons et là je pense que vraiment
les filles ont une longueur d'avancé
une équipe avec plus de mixité en
général ça fonctionne mieux
par ailleurs les visions sont
différentes et donc on est aujourd'hui
dans une société alors nous on le voit
particulièrement dans le domaine des
transports où le monde change
on va concevoir pour demain des
véhicules qui sont complètement
différent de ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui on a plus de créativité
quand il ya des visions des choses qui
sont différentes et donc les filles ou
une vision qui peut être intéressante
donc c'est typiquement des métiers sur
lesquels elles ont un rôle à jouer
fille ou garçon tous les chercheurs
peuvent prétendre à une bourse 2 le rc
du open research council
cette institution européenne veut
soutenir les meilleurs scientifiques
indépendants mais comment décrocher le
graal
nous avons rencontré son président jean
pierre bourguignon
le conseil européen de la recherche fait
partie intégrante du premier pilier
excellence scientifique du nouveau
programme de recherche et d'innovation
de la commission européenne horizon 2020
le conseil européen de la recherche a
comme principale activité de soutenir
les carrières de chercheurs indépendants
excellent dans tous les domaines
scientifiques il fut instituée
officiellement le 27 février 2007 il est
autonome depuis 2009
son président est jean pierre
bourguignon l'objectif est d'identifier
les meilleures idées et de retenir les
meilleurs cerveaux en europe en leur
conférant un statut et une visibilité
tout en attirant des talents étrangers
le jury est international est constitué
de scientifiques
il est très sélectif enjeux forts en
matière d'excellence et de budget le rc
propose trois types de bourses starting
grant subventions destinées aux jeunes
chercheurs de toutes nationalités
possédant entre 2 ans et 7 ans
d'expérience depuis l'obtention de leur
doctorat avec un parcours scientifique
très prometteur consolidateur grant
subventions destinées aux chercheurs de
toutes nationalités
possédant entre 7 ans et 12 ans
d'expérience depuis l'obtention de leur
doctorat et enfin advanced grant sans
limite d'âge
elle concerne tous les domaines
scientifiques de l'ingénierie et du
monde universitaire la france a le
meilleur taux de succès aux versets 674
grande île ont été attribués pour 1,3
milliard d'euros
les sommes versées sont vraiment un
emblème de la qualité scientifique d'une
institution aujourd'hui si on regarde le
périmètre de paris saclay il ya un peu
plus de 100 lauréats versées sur les
sept premières années
2 le rc notre espoir c'est que dans les
cinq à dix ans qui viennent
cet indicateur 7,7 marque de succès que
sont les versets augmente
progressivement dans notre périmètre de
l'université paris saclay je suis
toujours très content d'elle et son
terrain de rencontrer des lauréats de
l'horaire c'est parce que c'est toujours
à être important d'être confronté à la
diversité des pratiques de la recherche
donc là le nra pour la première fois
recevait un l'oréal de hercé donc
c'était l'occasion pour l'institution de
célébrer une seule façon mais aussi pour
moi de voir qu'un organisme finalisé
comme le terrain a tout à fait sa place
pour recevoir des lauréats bouleversé
parce que il intègre de la science
jusqu'à des produits technologiques
et maintenant une exposition inédite
quand l'art de la rue s'invite au cea le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives
ça donne le égales entre 215 c215 c'est
le nom du graffeur qui a pu investir les
lieux avec ses pochoirs
il signe des portraits étonnants de
marie curie d'albert einstein
il raconte la source à sa manière
regarde l'artiste un street artiste donc
est bien connu des gens du domaine de la
rue notamment en région parisienne en
particulier dans val de marne
du côté d'ivry et vitry qui a un
graffeur qui reconnut qui travaille au
pochoir
le but était de parler de science en
essayant d'avoir un vecteur et un
discours différent de celui qui
habituent l on voulait sortir de la
vulgarisation scientifique
essayez aussi de toucher d'autres
publics ce qui était déjà acquis par les
sciences donc on peut raconter
d'histoires qui est presque l'histoire
d'amour de marie curie avec pierre curie
on peut raconter la difficulté
historique pas avoir quelqu'un comme
eisenberg parce qu'ils étaient proches
du régime nazi raconte l'histoire de
rosalind franklin qui a réalisé des
images qui prouvait la structure en
double hélice de l'adn mail qui a été
volé entre guillemets par deux hommes de
cette découverte du prix nobel alors
qu'elle est même pas sifflé pour les
discours nobel n'avait envie de raconter
des histoires et à travers ces histoires
de par les tic
sa technique est complètement exploité
ici si ce n'est que le gros apport de ce
travail en commun ça a était de
d'ajouter de la profondeur et du sens à
son travail là où une représentation
dans la rue en vitrine dans le xiiième
d'un chat est avec une seule valeur
esthétique d'animation de la rue ici ça
devient le chat de schrödinger et ça
permet de parler de la mécanique
quantique sa part des fleurs un travail
d'histoire des sciences et de choses qui
peuvent être paradoxal on a essayé de
coller à des personnages qui sont en
rapport avec le cea saclay donc il ya
beaucoup de physique
donc on commence par a ils expertise
française dans le domaine du nucléaire
qui vient de henri becquerel marie curie
marie curie pierre curie en manquerait
de la famille curie rue cirque irène et
frédéric et ça s'est ensuite étendu
jusqu'à les figures d'historiquement
importante pour le ceva comme jean
perrin le général de gaulle
frédéric joliot des scientifiques
importants actuellement pour
l'université paris saclay quant à albert
fert
une rentrée qui se présente bien donc à
paris saclay place maintenant à l'agenda
lundi 28 et mardi 29 septembre vous avez
pu découvrir les projets de quaero et
d'edf avec les comités de suivi des
chantiers du quartier de moulins et
celui de l'école polytechnique
pour plus d'information notre site
internet eps.fr un rendez vous à ne pas
rater le 1er octobre les établissements
invite les étudiants et l'ensemble du
personnel à une après midi festive ou
demi journée de rencontres d'animations
et des changes et enfin le 12 novembre
une conférence tedx technology
entertainment design se tiendra alors
c'est l'objectif là aussi est de croiser
les idées de confronter les points de
vue les différents domaines
un seul mot d'ordre innover c'est
passionnant je vous invite vraiment à y
aller c'est le 12 novembre
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
déjà la fin on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de paris saclay
tv mais d'ici là toutes les informations
sont sur notre site au ppf point fr
merci